the people who are living in cities
represent a complexity of the human
experience that we've never
organized around if you have a democracy
and
you need your public to be able to be
engaged you need to have a system for
doing that
we actually don't have one for that kind
of problem
today on the podcast we're exploring the
world of civic design
and reimagining what public engagement
in demographically complex communities
might look like there are no complete
solutions
you have to learn how to make decisions
in the midst of ambiguity
which means for you internally you have
to have
your own dialogue for yourself
i'm your host sarah hansen in this
episode
i'm talking with an mit professor who
bravely navigates along the deepest
rifts in our public discourse
and who works with students and
communities alike
to step consciously into these spaces
my guest today is professor cesar
mcdowell who teaches course
11312 engaging community
but before we get into our conversation
we wanted to pause to remember
that so many of our ocw team members and
probably many of you
have lost people that they love over
this past year
and so we're dedicating this last
episode of season two
to all of our loved ones and to all of
yours and to all of those
who carry their light forward
professor mcdowell approaches his work
with community engagement like it's an
art form
in fact he's built an entire design
framework for practitioners
to shape and facilitate these
engagements but before we get into all
of that
we need to understand the main problem
his work seeks to address
his why if you will things are actually
changing in this country our populations
are changing
and right now in cities i think we're
just saying that
we're pronouncing anywhere else right
that the people who are living
in cities just happening to represent
a complexity of the human experience
that we've never organized around
and if you have a democracy and you need
your public to be able to
be engaged you need to have a system for
doing that
we actually don't have one for that kind
of public
a lot of professor mcdowell's course and
work center around the idea of democracy
but in this episode when we talk about
democracy
we're not talking about elections and
voting when professor mcdowell speaks of
democracy
he's talking about the engagements the
communities the conversations
the processes that we have as a public
to come together and make decisions
and a lot of these processes that we
traditionally consider democracy in
action
are a little outdated i'll tell you what
i mean
we don't have a democracy that works for
who we are i'll give an example
of how we hold on to something as a way
of thinking about democracy that does
not serve as well
right now if you kind of go back
to the founding of the country and you
look at the
original colonies they weren't the
original colors the people who came and
occupied the land and created these
opportunities for themselves here and
if you look at those they created this
thing that we hold as a myth today which
is this thing of the new england town
meeting town hall but if we're really
serious about looking at that there were
some things that were very true
about that it was mostly open to men
who were property owners most of these
people who are men and property owned is
lived in enclaves that share a religious
belief
okay so you take that as a core
and you build build processes around
that core that allow you to come to
decisions
right over time what we've been doing is
saying well
we don't want to be that exclusive we
want to let a few more people in so we
modify that a little bit more
and over time that's what we've been
doing and modifying it more modifying it
more
and then you get to something like the
presidential debates and what do we have
what do we say is the way we let the
public into this conversation
these televised town halls they have no
reality or connection to the complexity
of who we are
but we hold on to them as
our evidence that we are doing
and engaging the public around a
diaphragm
so this is what it means we don't have
it we actually don't have
a functioning infrastructure for
democracy
given the complexity of who we are so
that's what i mean by it's not just
about voting
it's the infrastructure that allows
people to do the work that the public
has to do
in order for democracy to function
the new infrastructure professor
mcdowell was talking about here
involves a shift away from the more
traditional forms of civic engagement
and participation
professor mcdowell's way involves
looking at a given situation
from multiple perspectives and then
spending time to reflect on our own
values and the needs of our community
one point in my life i lived in alaska
we had to love the arctic circle
i was associate superintendent of a new
school system there
that was the size of the state of
indiana and
villages 5 000 people no roads okay so
that's
that's the context predominantly uh
and there's this one instance in the
village where
we had a teacher who was
actually not performing very well in
this school and we were really concerned
the principal was concerned we were
concerned
and the teacher was angry in this
predominantly euphemia village and we
had decided to remove the teacher
because this is the best thing for the
kids just wasn't performing well
and there was a meeting in the village
where we talked about that
and there was a lot of
resistance and so uh the superintendent
asked me to kind of go
and try to find out what's going on and
so i went
and these little fellows you can do it i
talked to almost everyone
talk to a lot of people in the village
and here's
what was happening the school was saying
this
person is not a good teacher and people
were saying this person is a good
teacher
and we couldn't reconcile but what we
learned
when we started to kind of talk to
people
is that we were valuing the teacher in
very different ways
inside the school the good was really
applied for the school system the bill
was applied to how well
is this person taking care of the
educational needs
of the children for some of the people
in the community
teacher was a role good was the value to
the community
she was good for the community because
of other functions she played in the
community
and so we had this totally different use
of language
and they knew that if she wasn't there
as a teacher she wouldn't be there
because she'd have to leave
and so other values to the community
will be lost
[Music]
that kind of perspective taking i think
is so required
and as we find ways to bring people
together we have to
you know start to construct mechanisms
that allow people to do that kind of
reflection
and that kind of perspective taking in
relationship to the other
one of the challenges of getting people
to practice tuning into different
perspectives
is a physical one in our current
political climate
how do we even get people with different
perspectives in the same room
so we've started this campaign that
we're
testing out now it's called america's
path forward
in the campaign we're actually reaching
out to people in the public and we're
asking them
to do one thing and say two things
one is to donate the question they have
about the future of america
and the experience in their life that
led them to that question
and then what we do is we bring people
who have similar questions
and sometimes not into small
conversations
in those conversations all people are
doing is sharing their question
sharing their experience and what people
find
is when they go into these rooms with
people who have similar questions
they're surprised at who's in the room
because the thing that they hold as
what's theirs they're realizing well
there's a different set of people who
actually hold this too
and then when they hear different
experiences they're beginning to realize
oh this question manifests itself in
totally different ways
right it's the same question but it's
living out differently in our society
and for me this is a way of helping the
public build its own kind of reflection
and connection to others and what we're
trying to get people to do
at the end of these conversations is to
say if you could reframe this question
so that if it was addressed it would
more
likely attend to the different ways
you're experiencing
how would you reframe the question just
getting people to start to think that
way
holding the public as curious
intellectual beings and
encouraging them in that to say yes this
is hard work
and yes you can do it professor mcdowell
has worked with a team
to create a tool for having better
public conversations
the tool is called the civic design
framework i was curious about how the
design element
fits into this kind of community
engagement work yeah so when i think
about community engagement and design
the reason i put those two together is
to talk about the purposefulness of
how we go out in the world and create
engagement processes
and they actually are designed and can
be designed right
the main thing i'm trying to get people
to pay attention to is
when you're putting together an
engagement process
you have the ability to construct it for
certain kinds
of outcomes and processes that you want
to have having and connections you want
to have happen
therefore that's a design challenge
right given the population you work
within the issue you're going
to follow up with how then do you
construct that the sets of things that
can happen
so that they actually allow you to
bring people not just close together but
also what i like to say is help people
the public build its muscle for
democracy
the civic design framework gives us a
way into these conversations that are
central to having a truly functional
democracy
professor mcdowell teaches the framework
to students in 11312
engage in community we really use a
certain design framework
as a tool for organizing thinking in
projects
and the framework really has two
components to it
it's based on the notion that part of
the issue
of bringing the public in to any
engagement process
is we're not clear about what
conversation we're invited into
our problem in our public discourse in
engagement process is we often invite
people into one conversation and then
when they get in the room
we set them up for another so we will
say to them
come imagine a new sarasota florida
and you go into the room and you have
three choices to make
so basically you've set people up right
and
no wonder people are really dissatisfied
the other thing why it's important to
know which kind of conversation you have
is that they
each require something different if you
want to be in a framing conversation
with someone that's
totally different you're using really
different cognitive structures
than if you're in the ideation process
right because in the ideation process
you're trying to ignite
the imagination in a framing
conversation you're really trying to
deeply understand
experience and what's happening in the
world so those are very
different right and so if you don't know
what kind of conversation you want to
have in public
you're not going to design it the right
way
what's really exciting about professor
mcdowell's class
is that he doesn't just teach the theory
of this civic design framework
students are also invited to bring
forward actual cases
from the communities with which they are
already engaging where they can
implement the design
framework in real life i always try to
generate this opportunity for students
to say
here are the things we want to work on
and then to negotiate among themselves
which ones
they really want to move forward on we
did one in mexico
and that one is actually interesting it
was a former alum of our department
who had just stepped into this major
role in the new
government in the town in mexico
and they had got them through kind of a
popular
you know all grassroots campaign and now
they wanted to figure out how do we
carry that into
a structure into governance that
actually allows to get the public
involved and so the class is really
helping them through that design so it's
always that kind of
some problem some place where people are
trying to figure out how to broad and
diversify
how they're engaging with the public
one of the realities of collaborating
with real people in real communities
is that practitioners often find
themselves in situations
where solutions are complicated and
sometimes not complete
professor mcdowell offered some
important words of wisdom for
practitioners new to fieldwork
i think it's not just this course but in
terms of any real practice based course
that puts you out of
the field there are a couple things that
you have to contend with one
there are no complete solutions
right you have to learn how to make
decisions in the midst of ambiguity
you just you know you have to do it
which means for you
internally you have to have your
own dialogue to yourself
to understand how you're holding on to
the things that you believe
even though you're not able to really
achieve them
right within the midst of any one
project or any one initiative but you
still
not letting it kind of get to you and
one of the ways
we talk about this is i make a real
distinction in our class around
how we talk about things so for example
you know in our society i'm really good
at what i would say this kind of
language of evaluation
you know how well something is not we're
also good in language with critique
which is different than the evaluation
and we're really good at this language
of possibility
right now really looking into the future
what we're
not really good at is talking about the
reality what i call the language of
transition
the reality is we have things we want to
do
and as we're trying to do those things
to change systems we want to be
different we
have to support the systems that we're
trying to change
and so we live in this in-between space
a space called department that's where
we live and
in that space we have to learn how to
talk to each other and this is why i
always use these terms like grace and
stuff like that
because there's a recognition but that's
where you are
so in my class i try to support folks
being
able to talk about that about what
they're living with
in the middle what they're having to
hold on to that they don't
necessarily feel good about but they
know they have to do it is they're
trying to do this other thing and to
support them through that kind of
conversation this is a reflection of the
transition you're living in and just a
recognition of that and honoring it and
letting it be okay
right it's almost being able to have
a dialogue of forgiveness with yourself
i wanted to know what these engagements
look like in practice
so professor mcdowell shared with me one
example that took place in my very own
city of cambridge massachusetts
the dialogue was around domestic
violence and how the city could better
address the issue
and the engagement was simple professor
mcdowell and his team
asked residents of cambridge to donate a
question they had about domestic
violence
think about domestic violence that is
not
a public conversation right there's
nothing that people talk about
because we have the structure of all you
have to do is donate a question
a group of young people from cambridge
ranch and latin set up a booth
in harvard square they put up a board
and they made cookies and they just
basically had a thing a cookie for your
question
[Music]
and people would write their question
about the next survives and put on the
board and get a cookie
and then people started having
conversations
in public about what's on the board
and what they're hearing right so you're
taking something we don't talk about
moving forward
at the same time what we did is we took
all the questions that came in
printed them out very large and
we had a space in cambridge that we
could use where we put
all 2000 something questions up on the
wall
and we created a public event for people
to come in
read the questions and sit down and have
conversations with each other
about what they were seeing and hearing
and then we had people from the public
come in and say let's figure out
can we organize these questions and
certain kinds of themes and issues
and then we have conversations with
people about those things and issues
right so all this is like taking
something we don't talk about
and creating an opportunity for people
to do it because you're in some sense
recognizing that everyone has something
to say about this
right but if you do it in the right way
you don't try to tell them what they
have to say or how they have to say it
you just create that opportunity that
equalizes voices
people step up
this idea about equalizing voices and
bringing everyone to the table
is incredibly important in professor
mcdowell's work
one specific aspect of his design
framework speaks directly to this idea
it's built on the notion of equity and
it's a concept he calls
designing for the margins the reason i
use this concept of design for the
margins is
our default and everything we do
kind of design is designed for the
middle
where most people are and we do that
because we want to scale we want things
to grow fast we want to make sure we're
taking care of a lot of people
but the thing about when you desire for
those that are in the middle you're
mostly designing for people who you know
more or less
can operate within the systems that are
there and then what they end up doing is
pushing people into margins
further and further out and as
other things in our systems fail we end
up putting more and more people
into that margin and by the margins i
mean
those who are living with the failures
of the society
and so if we're going to attend that
and actually bring their voices in we
have to first
design opportunities and engagement
processes that work for them first
because those in the middle will find
their way into that because they have
the resources the opportunity they know
how to negotiate the system
the other thing when you design for the
margins you do
is because they're clearly living with
the failures of the systems
you're able to design around the things
that would normally keep people out
so it's a purposeful thing that actually
benefits more people if you actually do
and we have
instances of that in everyday life that
show us that
you know some physical ones you know
like the curb cut
right the curb cut was a thing it came
up
very particular movement from the
disabilities community
decades ago it created some access and a
lot of fights to get it done
but the interesting thing about it is
you look at it now and you say well who
benefits from that that's a design for
a very small population in the country
who benefits from it
who uses it well anybody rides a bicycle
pushes a trailer carries a grocery chart
stroller right strollers right it's all
there right
but that's not what it was designed for
it was designed for the margin but yet
all these central activities that people
involved in what i'm calling
the middle are able to benefit from that
too
the interesting thing about it and why
i'd actually like to use that example
is what have you noticed about
changes in curb cuts in the last decade
they have bumps on them now they have
texture to them and they have texture to
them
because it helps people
without sight to know they're coming to
a corner so the thing about designing
for the margins
it's not a thing that you achieve it's a
thing that you're always working at
because the margins will keep emerging
if you're anything like me you may be
thinking to yourself
that this is exactly the kind of work
that our country
and really our planet could use more of
better
more open more connected ways to engage
groups of people
around complex issues and a design
framework that allows us to keep working
at those issues
part of what i love about professor
mcdowell's work is that it's grounded in
doing
the hard work of community and community
together
the way that our systems are set up
right now
they really are designed to keep people
apart to disconnect people from each
other
groups from each other right and they
draw these false dichotomies
but in reality people live with a much
more complex set of things
right so for example you take the
movement from black lives
and you take away that in a very
powerful way
using the notions of defunding the
police you know some of the views
and others to change what policing is
right because
they have seen the evidence over and
over again
of the devaluing of black lives within
the midst of the police
however even with that same experience
knowledge space you can go into the
black community
and people have very different feelings
about
do we do from the police or not the
trading off of there
i know there's a risk but that risk is
in here and it's out there and i don't
know how to balance it
i don't know what to do about that right
when we
put things in our either or then we
really lose the opportunity
to really connect people or to create
some opportunity for people to
acknowledge what's the complexity that's
out there
and how do you negotiate that in a way
that doesn't leave people behind
or leave them to the side i should say
and you know you can use policing as
some you can use
what's happening in vaccinations there's
another there's a lot of things that are
just structured
and the way we talk about them in the
public doesn't recognize one thing that
we know is really true
our values kind of moderate a continuum
and what we're always doing
is trading off one for the other we're
going back and forth
right people are looking at things and
they're looking at that value
versus another value versus another
value
and why that's important for public
conversations is if we can step away
from saying
your value is this and mine is that and
you can get people in the space to
realize
oh this is how you trading off this set
of values and this is how i'm trading
them off
then when you realize that people are
holding half within the
same values they really are
just shifting and weighing them
differently at different times and that
creates
more of an opportunity for people at
least to see the other they may not
agree
but they begin to see the other and
that's you know
in our society where so many groups of
people have been so dehumanized
our first step is to let people be seen
through all the social upheaval and the
many defining events of 2020
professor mcdowell has continued to
spend a lot of his time engaging with
students
he often works with smaller class sizes
so that he can develop the close
relationships he feels are essential
this kind of close contact allows him to
see into students lives beyond the
classroom
and he shared with me some insights into
what he's seeing and what educators can
do to help
i think students are dealing with a lot
right now and it's not just because of
kodi i think our society is in a huge
transition
you know i can't tell you how many
students i have right now
who don't feel
connected to their families anymore
because of what's going on politically
in this country
that disrupture that people are sitting
with and so then you ask
how do we as educators
know they're sitting with this help them
to actually move forward in a way that i
was going to allow them
to be generative with other people
in the communities they work with and
also find their own path
and so for me teaching always has to be
grounded
in a reality you have to be working with
others who are actually dealing with the
problem
or the issue or who wants to do
something and you just have to work with
them and
it really is about lifting up and
supporting
people through that process of working
with others and working with yourself
in some ways a lot of my teaching is yes
it's about social
issues but it is also about
helping people develop not only just a
theory of practice
but a reflective strategy for themselves
as they move
through their careers into their lives
[Music]
there's a lot of excitement about
professor mcdowell's work in teaching
so we had some really wonderful listener
questions sent in for this episode
and we're excited to share two of them
with you now
here's one a listener sent in for people
who are used to having privileged access
to policy discussion and implementation
spaces
what habits should we watch out for are
there subconscious attitudes or
behaviors
that get in the way of including
historically excluded people
that's a really beautiful question i
think the
number one habit we have to watch out
for is a habit that we
actually understand the issue
right that we fully understand it we
have to make space
for people to be able to reframe the
issues we understand it
if we hold on to our frame from that
position
we will never really fully be able to
include others
so for me that's the critical
issue and that means we have to make
time and space for that
and that pushes against so much of what
we
you know these policy areas think about
because we try to do everything we gotta
do it
we gotta and i think
the mantra should be we're going to do
something
we're not going to get it quite right we
can take some time
to maybe understand a little different
we're going to do something there we're
not gonna get quite right
we're gonna take time to understand it
you know it's like
because that's the reality it is the
reality
so we have to acknowledge it
and to close one more listener question
one that very well may have been on your
mind while listening
is it easier or harder to have difficult
conversations
in small groups or large town hall
settings
how do we scale up dialogues how do you
adjust the questions the tone
the pacing to accommodate large and
diverse audiences
i'm a firm believer in small-scale
dialogues
to deal with really difficult issues
if we try to do it in large scale
audience we
one you can't have one voice in there
which means you're inevitably silencing
certain people
and i'm not saying don't do large-scale
events because it's good sometimes just
a certain place to listen
and hear and and watch others that's
that has value
but the transformational piece for
everyone i think is
being small space dialogues with others
i think we need work in turning our
technologies and designing our
communication systems
to support that kind of listening and
conversation and that's not what we have
right they're driven by other things and
that's one of the problems with them so
i think we can get that if we shift
our attention our design attention to
that and
the reality around it is all of our
incentives
for creating things like that are in the
opposite direction you know
you know it's like it's hard to build
technologies that are designed for the
largest that are gonna
actually scale right because you have
all these other things going on
it's a challenge i don't think it's a
challenge that can be met
if you're interested in learning more
about professor cesar mcdowell's work
or teaching with his open educational
resources you can check out his course
11312 engage in community on our mit
opencourseware website you can also
listen to his podcast
we who engage it's available wherever
you listen to podcasts
thanks for tuning in for our second
season of chalk radio
we hope you enjoyed these episodes and
will consider sharing this
or any of our other episodes with a
friend family member or colleague
we have more in store for season three
and are already working hard to bring
you more episodes
to inspire your teaching and learning
when chalk radio
returns in the fall signing off from
cambridge massachusetts
i'm sarah hansen from mit open
courseware
passed the car